Bladesmiths,
welcome to the forge,
where, typically,
we'd start you at your anvils.
There's no point today.
There are no tools.
Instead, your tools
are behind our very own
Forged In Fire...
[suspense music]
steel grate.
Or "grate wall." Ha ha.
Grate wall? Get it? G-R-A-T-E.
-Grate wall? Okay.
-[crickets chirp]
[all chuckle]
Your job is to free your tools
from this steel grate
and make a blade using nothing
but this grate wall.
Some of this is mild,
some of this is high-carbon.
It's up to your skill set
to determine what's what
and forge your blade.
The length of your blade
must be between
12 and 14 inches
with a through tang.
Good luck, bladesmiths,
your three hours starts... now.
[Bobby] We all go straight
to the grate wall
and we work as a team.
[buzzing]
I'm pouring sparks down
onto poor Dallas.
[Wil] These guys
just yanked this entry way
right out of our grate wall.
And now they gotta harvest
all those little pieces.
[action theme music]
[Wil] Look at Will,
he's just moving down his grate.
Very methodically
just knocking off
those small pieces of rod.
You got enough?
[Justin]
These tiny little pin stock.
You're not gonna stack it
all up
and weld it together
into a little billet.
So you gotta do
canister Damascus.
I'm skipping the White Out.
I'm just gonna forge-weld
that canister
right to the billet,
because
I can grind it off later.
[Bobby] The only canisters left
are canoe canisters
and I've never done
a canoe before.
I'm thinking, okay,
if this is gonna be the same
as a regular canister,
then I've got a lot more
welding to do.
I decided to use White Out
and let it dry
so the hard metal steel
and the powder
doesn't adhere to that.
[David] Bobby's got White Out
in his can.
He took time to dry it.
That's smart work.
They're really gonna try
and wow us with the pattern.
Removing that can
is gonna give us a better look.
[Bobby]
Weld in a topple in there,
weld in a work stick on it
and then the fire.
My welding skills suck.
I am just gopping this stuff
all around there
because I don't wanna have
any open seam
and it starts
shooting out sparks
and I gotta start over again.
My first squeeze on the press
feels really good.
It's solid. I can feel it go
all the way down.
[Doug] Bobby.
The color when he brought
that out was a bright yellow.
It got really massive
with the heat.
That thing's about to fall off.
I get my canister up to temp
and I start mashing it down.
I lose my handle at the press
because I'm a crappy welder.
[Wil] That's about
to pop off there, right there.
What're you gonna do, Justin?
-Weld like that-- There you go.
-There he goes.
[Justin] So I re-weld
the stick back on.
-Oh!
-Whoa!
And that falls off again too.
[Bobby] I'm looking around,
I see these other guys
already got blades.
I'm thinking I'm behind
the eight ball here.
[banging]
[Wil] Bobby is the only one
of our smiths
who freed his billet
from the can
so that put him a little bit
behind everybody else.
[David]
If Bobby works it now,
he could actually start
getting ahead of the pack.
He doesn't have to worry
about grinding any steel
off that blade.
[Bobby] Each press pass
runs really well.
And each time I gain
a little bit more.
And now I have something
that's beginning to look more
like a knife.
[Will] I used Big Blue
for the first time.
I start getting a rough shape.
But I have way too much steel.
So I chop it off right there
and then forged my tip.
[Neilsen] Will's finally
putting a tip in his blade.
Got a good amount
of material still to work with.
[Wil] And there we go.
We've got Bobby quenching
over there on anvil number one.
[Bobby] Don't feel any tugs,
cracks, tings.
My blade's straight.
I'm very pleased at this point.
[Justin]
I go over to the grinder
and I'm just trying to
"hog pall" this material off
so that I can get ready
for a quench.
I'm just praying
that I don't have a warp.
-Justin quenched.
-Okay.
[Justin] I pull it out,
it hardened, and I got a warp.
I don't wanna snap this blade.
So I let it cool down
a little bit in the vice.
Warp's there but not as bad,
so I think I can grind it out.
[machine buzzing]
Will has quenched his blade.
[Will] And it's warped.
Try to flatten it out
but I'm afraid it's gonna break.
So I heat it back up,
dunk it in the oil.
[judges] Whoa!
[shouts] Yo!
You want those eyebrows, kid?!
[Will] I grind as much as I can
and go straight into the edge,
[Wil]
Five, four, three, two, one!
Blademiths, shut down
your machines, drop your tools,
Pull your blades out
of the acid.
This first round of competition
is over.
Bladesmiths,
welcome to our strength test.
The sheet metal stab and chop.
I'm gonna take your weapons
and thrust and stab, chop, beat,
terrorize repeatedly into
these layers of sheet steel.
It's gonna be fun.
Now what your blades do
to the steel,
I'm not that concerned about.
I wanna see what the steel
is gonna do to your blades.
And, Bobby, you're up first.
-You ready, bud?
-Yes, sir.
[grunting]
Pretty brutal. [exhales]
All right, Bobby, good job.
-You survived.
-Thank you.
Tip penetrated nicely.
Went down
a little over half an inch.
Edge held up just fine,
no problem.
The handle...
leaves a bit more
to be desired.
-Yes, sir.
-It's a very lean guard here.
Edges are kinda sharp so I was
definitely using a glove.
-But it survived, so good job.
-Thank you.
-How you feeling, Justin?
-Nervous.
-[chuckles]
-Nervous? I'm not.
-Let's do it.
-All right.
[suspense music]
[grunting]
[grunts]
Ow.
My stomach drops.
There's a pinch point
or a hotspot on the handle
and it's hurt him.
Okay, this is one of the reasons
you wear the safety gear.
Justin, your pommel bit me.
And it didn't actually cut
a hole through the glove.
It was sharp enough
to actually cut my skin
through the fabric of the glove.
But that being said,
I like the contouring
you did on it, though.
Your edge got a couple spots
that had just a little bit
of glint to them.
Aside from that, you survived.
Good job.
Thank you.
Will, how you feeling?
[inhales] I'm optimistic.
It's a good way to be.
Let's see.
Yes, sir.
[grunting]
[grunts]
Cheer up, buddy. Good job.
You survived, Will. Good job.
It's all I could hope for.
A little bit of edge rolling
right here.
That's the biggest spot.
It's very small.
-But it's there.
-Yes, sir.
Biggest issue I had was
you got a warp in your blade.
So those first couple strikes,
I was way off to the right.
But edge is still sharp.
-Everything's tight. Good job.
-Thank you, sir.
-Oh, my god.
-All right, bladesmiths.
The strength test is complete.
Before we continue with testing,
I need just a moment to confer
with my colleagues.
The pommel was sharp enough.
Almost like a plow blade.
I just pushed in,
it was able to break the skin
while wearing a glove.
[tense music]
Justin, there's a big problem
with your blade.
It hurt Jay
while he was using it.
And a blade should never hurt
the end user.
And for that reason,
you cannot move forward
with testing
and you cannot move forward
in this competition.
I'd like to invite you
to shake my hand,
shake your judges' hand,
shake your competitors' hand,
and then please exit the forge.
Come on, my friend.
You did great.
[indistinct whispers]
[Justin] Judges
made the right call.
And I hope I get
the opportunity to come back
and try again.